I really hate it when you find out that
a really sweet looking celeb ends up
being a jerk in real life well don't
worry because my fave actor Paul Rudd is
actually way nicer than you think he is
be real how many times have you imagined
getting that call from Kevin feige that
you're a superhero in the MCU I always
imagine I'm gonna be cast as Spider Gwen
but hey that's just me back when Rudd
got the legendary call for Ant-Man
Marvel wasn't as well known he kind of
felt like he was joining Dancing with
the Stars and actually he kind of was
once it came time for him to join all
the rest of the Avengers for civil war
he got roped into filming a big dance
number for the cast Paul Rudd met most
of the extended cast including Chris
Evans Jeremy Renner and Chadwick Boseman
by asking them to do a silly dance that
would be cut to the song We Go Together
from Greece honestly I would have paid
20 bucks to see that on IMAX instead of
quantumania oh do you really because it
didn't look like it for my end Paul Rudd
brought things to the next level on
Quantum Mania I mean it's really hard to
look like you can hold your own with the
villain of the decade Jonathan Majors
just look at how intimidated even
Michael B Jordan looks getting into the
ring with that dude that sure wasn't
Paul's biggest acting challenge though
nah we gotta look at Anchorman for that
on a film like that the challenge isn't
so much getting intense as it is keeping
a straight face when you got co-workers
like Steve Carell and Will Ferrell not
laughing is actually the biggest
challenge if you laugh you ruin a take
and hold up the whole production there
was one scene the entire cast struggled
to get through Steve Carell's brick ends
up eating a Falafel that is mostly
coffee filter and they lost it every
time he took a bite but here's the thing
if it had Mayo on it he never would have
made it okay first piece of Paul Rudd
trivia he hates mayonnaise so much so
that if you re-watch clueless you'll see
the man literally doesn't know how to
spread Mayo he spreads it on the turkey
not the bread this was your big break
man you couldn't just ask Alicia how do
you make a sandwich clearly 25 year old
Paul Rudd was the real clueless one from
the movie came out and said oh I was not
good this was far from the most awkward
moment for young Paul Rudd though have
you ever been to a party with people you
didn't know and then they were all
emotional and Huggy and you were just
kind of there awkward right well that's
exactly what it was like for Paul Rudd
filming the Friends finale really don't
get me wrong he dug getting to be on the
show and they were super happy to have
him the whole reason he ended up with
Phoebe was because he and his character
Mike were universally liked when it came
to film the finale though the core cast
was super emotional they'd been on this
like life-changing Journey for a decade
then Paul comes in for the last little
bit and he gets to be there for the last
episode yeah that's gotta be weird no
wonder he didn't make the reunion well
nothing could have been as fun as making
Wet Hot American Summer okay now imagine
you're going to a crazy awesome party
with Amy pohler Bradley Cooper Elizabeth
Banks Molly Shannon and Janine Garofalo
that was basically what it was like
during the whole time they were shooting
wet Hot American Summer the entire cast
lived at the summer camp and had too
much fun during the shoot several
members of the cast talked about how
they were inebriated pretty much the
entire time it's pretty cool pretty sure
Paul Rudd partied a little too hard
because he admitted that he had no idea
if he ever got paid for making the movie
okay time for Paul Rudd trivia too have
you ever wondered what the secret is
behind Paul Rudd's super nice attitude
well apparently his secret origin is
that when he was in like fourth grade he
transferred schools and it was really
scary for him there was one kid who
broke the tension by introducing himself
to Paul and making him feel welcome Rudd
still thinks about that dude and tries
to live like him every single day there
are so many stories about how Paul
Rudd's like the nicest guy in Hollywood
that I don't even know where to start
like one time a kid got internet famous
because no one would sign his yearbook
and they bullied him all the time Paul
Rudd literally facetimed this little
dude wrote him a heartfelt message as if
he were signing his yearbook and sent
him a signed Ant-Man helmet I can't even
talk about this or I'm gonna straight up
cry all over YouTube like it's too sweet
and I can't he also heard that a
legendary Candy Shop in Rhinebeck New
York was closing down he and Jeffrey
Dean Morgan yeah that Jeffrey Dean
Morgan decided to buy it to keep it from
getting shut down seriously if you're
ever in the area go to Samuel's Sweet
Shop they don't even sponsor this on
just being real with you it's amazing
also how weirded out would you be if
your new bosses were Paul nicest guy
ever Rudd and freaking Negan from The
Walking Dead that's a good cop bad cop
scenario if I've ever seen one though my
favorite Paul Rudd story has got to be
this one time that a woman was on a
flight with Paul to Kansas City she
really wanted to go over to him and
recreate his legendary moment from
hotwicks like she'd go hey look at us
who would have thought and he would have
gone not me so missed opportunity right
wrong fade had other things in mind she
actually bumped into him at the Kansas
City Chief's locker room and was
naturally very excited to see him she
was like Hey I'm the girl from the plane
and you already know what he said hey
look at us who would have thought wow
it's all just feels so overwhelming and
incredible this shouldn't even be a
surprise because obviously Paul Rudd is
an amazing dad like his kids thought he
worked at a movie theater instead of
being a big time movie star and he did
not correct them he always keeps his
kids away from the public eye his son
didn't even realize how famous his dad
was until he was like 15 years old can
you imagine just like stumbling onto I
Love You Man on Netflix and being like
dad though there's one thing I would
never forgive him for if I were his kid
his daughter dressed up as the WASP for
Halloween then you'd think he would
dress like Ant-Man right perfect
Halloween nah he dressed as Weird Al he
would never hear the end of it I gotta
say thank you to that fourth grader who
made Paul Rudd into the nice guy he is
today not all heroes wear capes or ant
helmets
foreign
[Music]